[Music]
they killed my man
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the predator
[Music]
[Music]
what's the big one doc you sound like
the male
[Music]
you know I never would let me guess he's
done something crazy
[Music]
she told me again I want to break your
neck
well the moody bless okay Nebraska
rhythms s quarter
that's Lynch quick moves Wow
I don't think he believed
mock me I had a run-in with a space in
there
the rest of us focus on that's the thing
that killed my man aliens
but it's exploiting weakness tracks its
prey but again seems to enjoy it it's
not a predator that's a sports hunter
well we took a vote
predators cool it right
x9r with PTSD 19 that's mental you're
insane right the large
fast and [ __ ] UUP's their idea
tourism
figured something out I think we're
gonna die
just pointing it out a big boys a hunter
he brought his dogs with me
the predator only in theaters September
14th the only thing between us and them
these guys Kenna Army Ranger sniper and
certified badass Nebraska the muscle you
just Joe somebody sorry don't question I
was a dumb question
Oh
Neville's back slave crazy crazier
laziest
it's called the predator it hunts people
for sport
relax we're the good guys oh that's cute
oh this is the crew
you wanna give away yeah that's gonna
save our asses
come and get us
do you know what my job description is
I'm in acquisitions I look up and I
catch what falls out of the sky
tell me about the mission did you see
anything unusual it's above our bakery
[Music]
look I get it
something went down in Mexico nobody
wants any witnesses we need to know if
you and your man pose a threat
we're Rangers Baxley if your mom's
vagina were a video game to be rated E
for Everyone some pose on the three kind
of the [ __ ] point
predators just don't sit around making
hats out of rib cages the conquered
space but that's not what's on the
horizon should I be worried
Riley I think you know what is on the
ship the ultimate predators
we may die
we're still here
so come and get us [ __ ]
tell me about the mission did you see
anything unusual like an alien you mean
after 30 years of predator movies it's
the right time to resurrect the
franchise and blessed have the
opportunity to play in that sandbox
there's an honor of privilege to get to
come back with Shane to reinvent this
thing with a ball because he's so
knowledgeable it's amazing someone
Similac some experience love growing
this stuff trying to encompass in one
movie all genre things that we love
this movie has everything you want it's
gonna be exciting
with predator there's another level of
menace of terror the predator can take
this is the scariest one uptrending the
predator to a next level of deadliness
the upgrade who's gonna scare the mess
out of people it's just bigger and
better and badder
predators they will conquer this planet
do you have a plan for ex- PTSD in a
tune that's mental wanna kill oh oh yeah
why'd you just say so
with fries and a hot environment maybe
they want to move it you're insane right
yeah what is that the ultimate predators
I think we're gonna die just point it
out
wicked are all right everybody we're
hanging out on one of the ways in which
we pass the time is we like to have a
little bit Bates today's debate who
would win between the predator versus so
we're throw out a couple of ideas would
love to hear your feedback I'm gonna
start off with the rock he throws the
smile done he hits it with the wing with
the way I smell what The Rock is cookin
that could be close what about predator
versus the Punisher I knew that was I
mean I'm sorry but it's just it's it was
his begging it's no begging just no
contest right the predator wins I mean
like to do this from a different planet
so I bacteria bacteria know what I mean
well you know you've battled both
predator and chlamydia bro the predator
versus oh I don't know a young lady a
villain perhaps by the name of Cylon
whites what watch out oh that is a sharp
vs. Johnny oh no he would kill Charlie
you try you stripper man he regenerate
regenerate so he will keep coming back
over and over again I like I like walrus
I like when I like worry they got to
Logan Bigelow predator versus it town
what he got I say it would be pretty
short movie predator versus Yoda Yoda he
gonna win easy
how so we told how confuse him to death
oh he's got the force got oh of course
murder does have the force yeah
[Music]
[Music]
tell me about the mission did you see
anything unusual like an enemy he saw
something
oh yeah yeah then you men someone or
something tore him to pieces
I think they're attempting hybridization
they're upgrading on every plant they
visit we need to know if you pose a
threat
we're assassins there's imposing the
threat kind of deployed
[Music]
but it is real conquer this planet do
you have a plan X [ __ ] with PTSD and a
team that's mental you wanna kill him oh
yeah
why did you just say so
we thrive in a hot grinder and [ __ ]
you up their idea of tourism let's get
some what is that the ultimate predator
[Music]